rachel what's going on how can i help my
fiance and i are
planning our wedding for september and
um among the conversations that we were
having
was that he anticipates um being a
caregiver
caregiver for him two of his brothers
with
mental disabilities and
so i just wanted some advice on how to
navigate that
i hear in your voice that you were not
expecting that
and you were not looking forward to this
i i kind of did but as the wedding
starts approaching it just becomes more
of a reality
and it kind of just um
solidifies um i know that to a certain
extent
what is this what does it solidify are
you is this a deal breaker for you
no no no absolutely not it's just
essentially trying to figure out how
much of
a how much of a like a
a mental and emotional burden it would
be on our relationship and our future
and so he's just trying to process that
and kind of figuring out the best way
to deal with all of it without
um without offending people on the
process
without like stepping on anybody's toes
in the process and things like that
so so it's going to be a big strain
and it's going to be hard and it's still
probably going to be the right thing
those aren't all mutually exclusive and
having a good marriage is hard it's
gritty and annoying and
frustrating and lots of tears and then
you get up and you do it again
and as the great therapist terrence real
says
one person's always jumping off the deep
end and it's the other person's job
they're not jumping after him right um
somebody's got to stay stable
that's part of it um
there's something deeper here what do
you mean you don't want to step on
people's toes and make people frustrated
what do you what do you mean by that
well
obviously like the the mental
disabilities for
both of us brothers have been going on
for a long time
and they are both very
functional they can they're able to hold
jobs to a certain extent
but also there's also
the part where i know that like
he wants to he anticipates taking care
of
them emotionally and possibly
financially in the future
but it's also the part where he doesn't
wanna
um he knows it's gonna be his
responsibility but he doesn't wanna i
guess
overstep his boundaries as far as with
his parents
okay but he feels like he knows it
because he was sharing with me that
early on
um i guess something happened when he
was still very young
in his teenage years where he realized
that
oh this is going to be on me in the
future does he have any brothers and
sisters
i'm sorry does he have any brothers or
sisters
uh yes he has one more brother
and that dude's m.i.a not gonna help
um yeah he will we just don't know how
the situation is gonna be
is your husband is he being a martyr
he's the oldest
maybe i mean
have to do all this stuff and i'm gonna
is that is it that too
no no i think that he just feels the
responsibility being the oldest okay
that he he's gonna need to take to step
up and take care of him
okay so this is a
potential issue way down the road
and it sounds like there's a lot of
what ifs a lot of future
what ifs that we're allowing to poison
our right now okay
and so all of this is solved with a
really straightforward
not even hard but a straightforward hey
we're all sitting down having a
conversation
with his parents with your his brother
and him
and my brother and i have done this my
sister and i have done this my dad and
my mom have had this conversation
now we don't have special needs kids in
the house but we do have
various situations in our family here's
how this is going to happen
if i pass away here's how this is going
we just walked through that together
um and so if i'm your brother
i mean i'm sorry if i'm your fiance i
just made that weird if i'm your fiance
um i would call my parents
and say hey let's i want to talk through
what's the what's the plan i need to
know if there is a
um a special needs trust which should
have been set up for those boys already
um what is what is y'all's plan as you
all
age are they gonna continue to live just
get it all out in the open
there's nothing to be weirded about here
there's nothing to be ashamed of about
here
this is just something that you got to
deal with head on and
then once you know and begin to make a
plan then you begin to make a plan
a plan is about as useful as when the
actual situation shows up
right as mike tyson says everyone's got
a plan until you get hit in the mouth
and then things change so you have a
plan and you hold it really loosely
you'd be graceful with one another
you on the other hand need to ask
yourself
are you going to be married to this guy
with potentially two of his brothers
moving into your home
i hear something in your voice that says
that you're not comfortable with this
you feel weird about this you're
stressed about this
and um you need to know now
going in the kind of guy you're marrying
is a guy that says i'm going to take
care of my family
and i agree with that and i i
anticipated that
and i'm completely okay with it it's
just
i feel like between the two of us we can
handle it
but then when there is everybody else's
input
and what we you know how we decide to
help and things like that
is when things get more complicated yeah
and they don't get a vote
they don't it doesn't matter what they
say right now if they're on
a part of the special needs trust if
they have holes over the money if
they're the executor of the will then
yeah they're going to have a
choice and you think there is no such a
thing to begin with yeah you can get one
with enough
planning they need to get one of those
yesterday yesterday they need to get one
of those
um that's a that is an asap
do not pass go get that thing done okay
you want to make sure your kids are
taken care of especially with special
needs after you're gone
um i cannot emphasize how important it
is to have a will
have a will have a will have a will if
you've got children with special needs
have a special needs trust
do it yesterday um
these are not hard conversations and i
don't mean to make make a light of this
rachel these are just
direct let's just have this thing and
let's all get on the same page here
um i would be happy
to marry somebody who's cares about his
family and he's thinking down the road
what y'all both need to do is don't cash
out your present day
happiness your present day excitement
over about something that may or may not
happen years down the road
okay life is too short things are too
bananas you need to enjoy what you have
today and you need to be excited about
the fact that you're about to get
married
if for some reason do you say i'm out of
this thing
i just don't want to have a future where
i've got two other
grown men living at my house man have
the dignity to let him know now
and then walk away with your head up
head held high if that's what you choose
um don't go into this
marriage knowing where your your
fiance's heart is
knowing the situation of his brothers
and then
slowly drag the whole machine underwater
and drown everybody in the process there
are going to be a lot of people with a
lot of opinions on this
but if your brothers i mean if your
fiance is the one poning up the money
pony up the house
taking care of them nobody else gets a
vote zero none
just y'all two y'all get to craft this
what this looks like y'all two get to
decide
who gets a vote so here's what i want
you to do as a as a premarital exercise
i want you guys to get a real box
like a shoe box a little fancy bot i
don't care what it is the real thing
put it on your kitchen table and i want
you
to write out four or five people on
planet earth
who get a vote into your marriage that
could be another couple that you all
know that could be a marriage counselor
that could be
close friends that you each have that
could be whoever you want
and put it in there and i want you to
close that box and let it sit for a day
then i want you all to circle back and i
want you to open it up each of you
together and explain to the other person
why you're doing what you're doing
why are you giving this person a say
into our marriage into our relationship
what are we talking about here
why are we doing this and then here's
the thing once y'all agree on who goes
in that box
nobody else gets a vote his mom can call
you and say i just thought
that he would have married somebody who
i don't you don't get a vote
right you're gonna be respectful of
course but you don't get any input
well we just expected at christmas y'all
we're gonna well i appreciate
that so much but we're not gonna do that
we're going to arkansas we're going to
the moon we're going to wherever right
you all get to decide that as a couple
but have those conversations up front
have them right now and the names in
that box will evolve and shift and
change over time
but it's the intentionality exercise of
who are we letting speak into this house
it's not in-laws it's not my parents
it's not
the vet it's not the fill in the blank
right whoever else it's gonna be
right um and then just sit down with his
parents and have a honest
direct straightforward conversation i'm
about to get married
i'm about to start creating my own
legacy my own household
and i have the expectation i'm gonna be
taking care of my two brothers down the
road
what is y'all's plan what does y'all's
will look like what is the plan moving
forward for when we're going to
transition this
and then have that direct conversation
put everybody on notice that this is how
this is going to be
and they go from there i appreciate that
call rachel i know that sounds complex
and hard and scary especially when i'm
not even married yet
but there's not a way to go into that
other than directly
and not being an idiot and a jerk and i
know y'all wouldn't do that but going
there with dignity and respect and a
on the on the table what are we gonna do
about
our my brothers